I played roulette a little bit and this
dude
was
this handsome dude who was like 54.
just betting
thousands of dollars each roulette like
I'm talking about there was like
there were like spins that had 10 000 of
his dollars on the board
and he was just like what does it matter
what does it matter you know what does
it matter eh what does it matter he kept
saying and I was like well yeah he's
like it doesn't matter you put this here
you put this there it doesn't matter
he's telling me and he starts telling me
jokes like jokes you'd read from a book
but here's what happened he goes like
this
he puts a five thousand dollar chip on
three
okay
he's got a one in 37 chance of turning
this into one hundred and eighty
thousand dollars okay or whatever it is
so he puts it on three
the things spinning right before the
dealer says no more bets the dealer or
whatever you call him because he's not
dealing anything really takes the Chip
And he says I don't think you really
want to make that bet do you tosses it
off back to the guy and then the [__]
ball lands on three
okay
so the guy says what the hell did you
take that off for
and the guy says well I didn't think you
really wanted to bet on it and he says
but that's why I put it there and he
says Nah well it doesn't you know it
wasn't there so we can't pay you and the
guy's like I put it on there
and then he says get the Pit Boss
because this guy's own 180
The Pit Boss comes by and is like what
happened here we explain and the Pit
Boss says no the maximum bet here is 500
so that bet is void anyway you're
getting nothing and then David Sullivan
was there and he says nah man I saw it
that's not fair he put that chip there
he should get that money you should at
least give him the 500 bet which is 18
Grand okay and the Pit Boss says this
has got nothing to do with you to David
Sullivan and David Sullivan says yes it
does I was a witness and I was like
that's actually pretty dope it was
witnessing it doesn't have something to
do
so the Pit Boss leaves to make a call I
don't know what we call like Jesus
Christ or something I don't know who
above is above in The Pit Boss but he's
on the phone for [__] 15 minutes and
I'm chilling we can't do anything else
so we're just the Spanish Guy starts
saying like
like just he was so from a goddamn movie
it was unbelievable first of all waiting
to see if he's gonna get eighteen
thousand dollars cool as a cucumber
betting thousands and thousands of
dollars and says a guy walks into a bar
and I was like dude are you are you
kidding me
like are you kidding me right now
a guy walks into a bar he opens up the
box says to the bartender what do you
think's in this little box tells me some
sort of and I'm like oh yo dude we're
not doing this
I gotta now I gotta pretend to have
bigger jokes tells me a joke it's fine
you know it's a written joke he
obviously read it somewhere and we were
like oh yeah that's funny yeah and David
Sullivan under breath says I heard that
one man so I was like oh yeah okay cool
next one
it was a sunny does another joke second
joke and he says I'm sorry man but I'm
just waiting biting time I'm really
sorry that all this is happening and I
said it's okay man he says what do you
guys do I said well we're all Comedians
and he says oh no he gets embarrassed
because you're tons of [__] jokes
hilarious
The Pit Boss comes back
and says okay we'll give you the
eighteen thousand dollars so this dude
just makes 18 000 off of the one hand
right and then says thank you for guys
for being with me and actually like
having my back and [__] I want to come
to your show tomorrow and I want to take
you all to dinner
so we did we went to dinner with a guy
named Emmanuel who is Spanish
and it was [__] so good dude and that
[__] is Vegas
it was so gangster crazy crazy crazy
crazy
[Music]